welcome to waters world i'm jesse waters
the media is getting nervous that's the
subject of tonight's water's words
the democratic debate was awful bunch of
boring losers with bad
ideas i had to watch it because i get
paid to and here's what i learned
democrats want to bribe terrorists not
kill them
whenever there's a threat to america
their only answer is to quote
bring people together whatever that
means
they know nothing about trade they say
trump's bad on trade
but then they vote for his trade deals
profits are bad
except when donors give their profits to
them then that's good
gasoline is evil we're going to get rid
of gasoline when they're president not
sure how
i'm going to fill up my tank or what i'm
going to fill it up with they won't tell
you that
and finally we need free government run
day care
like anyone on stage would give their
newborn to a government worker
for the whole day the government
couldn't even guard jeffrey epstein
the most important person in u.s custody
and you trust them to guard your baby
wait until trump faces off against these
guys
he's going to chop him into pieces and
he's going to smile doing it
he's even cockier and looser now than he
was
when he debated crooked and he's wrapped
up a record of accomplishments that he
can talk about
record economy bigger paychecks trade
deals
cheap gas no new wars isis bombed away
it's going to be a bloodbath finally the
democrats and the media
are starting to see it i didn't see
anybody in there
on the stage last night or in the ring
that really said i'm taking
charge i can be president i can take on
donald trump there was nothing i saw
tonight that would be able to take
donald trump out there was nothing
tonight
that if you're looking at this thing you
say this any of these people are
prepared for what donald trump is going
to do to us
they will mark this day january 13th
as the day donald trump was reelected
because once again the democrats the
liberals the left
couldn't get it together when sharpton
van jones and michael moore and i
agree it's got to be true but the media
hasn't thrown in the towel yet
they're going to fight to the death even
if it means fighting with each other
and cracks are starting to show msnbc is
now
attacking cnn that's one of the reasons
why trump kind of
wants you to watch cnn instead of msnbc
sure because he knows
on msnbc there will be no one defending
him because we don't bring on liars
i don't bring on a liar i won't do that
and there's no one on cnn who are you
saying that to defend trump
you have to lie yes absolutely
absolutely of course yes how else do you
defend a liar
a pathological liar who lies about
everything you have to lie so
cnn has people on the payroll who they
pay to tell their lies
to the cnn audience in the middle of you
know
a cnn hour for some number of minutes
shots fired
this is rare these cable channels
usually go after each other like that
and here's what it tells you msnbc is
getting desperate
the prime time ratings over there
they're down big especially o'donnell's
because their audience is depressed
they've been lied to too many times
no collusion no high crimes that takes a
toll on you
now cnn they've ticked up a little bit
during impeachment
and yeah once in a while they'll put a
republican on
once in a while they'll have one guy on
or
one white house official on defending
trump
msnbc can't accept that msnbc can't
tolerate
debate they're intolerant anything they
disagree with is a lie
so msnbc won't interview a guest who
believes trump's doing a good job for
america
they shut down conservatives it's cable
news totalitarianism
liberals can't debate you so they
silence you you see that
in social media on college campuses
does lawrence o'donnell sound like a man
confident in his ideas
no he sounds scared to me that's what's
happening
they're running scared because trump's
winning they hate to admit it
some have the guts to say it like what
we showed you others like lawrence
they just try to hide it from their
audience
msnbc doesn't put on liars their own
anchors
lied about collusion for three years
or how about this lawrence was
practically giddy
about hosting this liar sitting beside
me right now i'm not gonna let you cheat
you have to guess
uh and hint his name is michael avenatti
now that liar is behind bars today he
lied about kavanagh
gang raping people he lied to investors
to creditors he stole from his clients
he's bankrupt
busted for extortion msnbc so gullible
they're filled with so much rage they
just get played
now msnbc is trotting out another liar
facing hard time a guy named lev
parnis or whatever he's supposed to be
the next
silver bullet to take out trump remember
full of bombshells bombshell after
bombshell this guy's changed his story
a dozen times turns out he's never even
talked to trump about ukraine
never even cnn had to call bs on msnbc
we can't ignore harness has a serious
credibility problem he's under
indictment for campaign finance charges
uh the foreign minister of ukraine told
cnn's christianity that he doesn't trust
a word parnis is saying and yet i see
people
out there in social media democrats
acting as if this guy is the second
coming of theodore roosevelt or
something
so more shooting inside the liberal
media tent
go at it boys we'll just sit back and
see it for what it really is
the left getting more desperate the more
it looks like trump
will get re-elected